there are certain items i find that you
would just never see in like in a guy's
place or just a guy like a bachelor pad
for example yeah like um like i don't
trust any guy who buys candles right
i buy candles
oh my god what's wrong i love candles
man they're great stress relievers i
mean they're great
wait wait you like you buy candles
because you like baths right i love
baths okay that's that's that's the
reason that's that's the [ __ ] reason
i i don't
i i'd say i take a shower like just a
shower without a bath combo maybe once a
month really i don't i just bath every
day damn so how often how often do you
use your candles
my candles well um
right now obviously uh been moving i
haven't really been using them yeah i'd
say normally i used to like light it
like twice a week
twice a week twice a week like do you
have one for like each room no just my
office oh just your office okay okay i
don't really near my bed i don't trust
it it might just like spill i just like
like i i i like having a nice scent in
my room but there's just something about
candles and just having an open flame
somewhere in your room that just makes
me really uncomfortable dude
[ __ ] candles and throughout the house
yeah i'm like everywhere i look as a
fire hat i know i know right now
i i never put a candle in a room that
i'm not in
i would never do that oh yeah no see i'd
never light a candle while i'm not in
the room yeah i i could sketch shitless
when i'm like working all day and then i
go to the we live in japan yeah go to
the go to the earthquake yeah yeah and
they go to the bedroom and there's like
three candles lit up and i'm like what
what do you want this room to smell like
yeah when you go to bed yeah it's fair
but not not when you're not in the
bedroom which is dangerous i mean it
smells good don't get me wrong but it's
like one is enough
yeah where did when did you start buying
cabbage no i got really into it i used
to go like candle subreddits for like
candle recommendations
what i swear this has happened in the
time period that i started to know you
because i was like i went to your place
and i've never seen yeah i got really
into it in london i uh i had like four
candles in my bedroom was it [ __ ]
xena that got you into it no no i i was
the candle guy
i was all me
i bought one candle at the store one day
and i thought this is good but it could
smell better and then i i looked for a
scent that i thought would be better
yeah and i found one i liked um and i
started like learning what gives a good
uh a good scent you know a lot of them
don't really do good scents you know
like the very you know when you sniff it
and uh like floral ones and uh like
grassy type smells they don't [ __ ] do
anything like when you when you burn
that [ __ ] it's not gonna last right
there's a few that like like the really
strong like fruit ones like cherry and
stuff that'll stay in your room for like
a week i just i just i just want to know
like okay so you got into candles for
the sense right yeah why not buy like
one of those
something that's not a candy so i i do
uh try the uh
yeah
there's
[Music]
okay i [ __ ] with incense
i'm a [ __ ] monk
yeah wait wait wait wait the uh wait
what's the
sorry i've forgotten the difference in
sense of what you burn right yes
it's not like what are the the water the
oil soaking ones what are they
they're both incense yeah they're both
they're the different things
so the burning ones are good as well i
like those the burning ones are good for
like if you need an instant hit like
yeah if you just need it if you just
need to make no it's true
you're totally right the the internet
sticks when you burn them are much
better for like an instant like you want
to cleanse the room yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah nice clean scent yeah and you say
smokey it's not smokey it's it's got a
nice chard sent to it that really
happens it's just it's very relaxing
yeah it's very relaxing i can see why
you know every every [ __ ] massage
place has one yeah i like the uh i find
that the the oil ones are very good if
you want to have a like 24 hour one for
like uh you know like maybe two weeks
tops i i i think the oil ones are the
best and i like i and i feel like a lot
of guys don't really consider sense
oh i i have one and the only like the
only reason i did was because i started
dating someone and then and then i'm
just like this is uh this actually
smells actually uh make the room feel
good
who [ __ ] knew right i have one in my
living room bedroom and office yeah
because i just want to have every i want
to have every room centered but i'm just
like why why use candles when you have
the oil sticks or the incense because
candles are aesthetic candles are more
of a you know if you really want to feel
like you're relaxing the flame along
with it's like a fireplace it's it's
it's a safe fireplace you know
you can't get a fireplace in japan so
the next best thing is because candles
don't make you know there's if you're
[ __ ] stressed as [ __ ]
i can't an open flame next to the carpet
are you kidding me like in japan
one little earthquake in the end
the right size make sure it's not
burning too aggressively make it burn
slowly the [ __ ] are you talking
i had like specific scissors for
trimming wicks why are you serious yeah
because i used to buy big cats
how am i just finding out know i just
like i don't know it's just candles you
know it's nothing not a big deal
i just i i have a lot of guys
i used to buy so occasionally i'd buy
like those like yankee candles that's
like the that's like i've just gotten
into candles cam yeah i mean these are
basic [ __ ] candles you know what i mean
this is baby's first i'm i'm getting are
you really about to gatekeep candles
honestly no no no no no he's he's a
candle connoisseur because the yankee
candles
you get very uh very artificial scents
and you get like you can get like big
ones and you get like a good value for
money but the problem is that because
they're so big they're like this [ __ ]
big after like
uh one week or two days of using it
they're [ __ ] good tunnels right down
it's a candle turn by the way tunnel
like you wouldn't understand if you went
into it
no but it like so it goes right down and
you have to like but depending on how
you burn it you can't just keep burning
it otherwise it will just dig down
so you have to like you have to be smart
you buy like custom-made candles
i really like them when you go to there
were some candle stores in london that
did really nice candles really expensive
but man the scents were so nice and you
would get like really nice spreading
sense a lot like i said like i'd say
half of the candles out there like that
you can get an amazon [ __ ] don't do
anything they're just lazy they just
burn and then you're like i can't smell
[ __ ] yeah great like the scent should be
strong but not last too long no i'm i'm
part of the incense master race that
that is good that's that to me
i both have their place
nothing to me can beat an incense
and to me candles are just like the
middle child yeah dude
i wonder why
i got in the dictionary in
in the sense i like these two
[Music]
one of like the most surprising tangents
we've ever gone on trash taste i swear i
mentioned i like candles before no
you've never never you've never that's
why we're freaking out neither on trash
taste or in real life
this is real life joey also it's great
you know you can i'm easy to buy gifts
for you you can just buy me a nice cat i
wish i [ __ ] knew that she's got a
nice candle because every time i'm like
well [ __ ] he has everything jojo related
i literally can't get him anything
anymore but now i know you like candles
so i'll just get your [ __ ] candle
give me an expensive candle a nice one
don't give me a chance yeah but now you
have to get a candle that impresses him
yeah oh great
don't get me i don't like candles that
are like carved into shapes that's a
load of nonsense you're just tacking on
values into nothing get me a good candle
you know what i mean like i just
yeah i mean that's uh there's a lot of
nice channels out there shout out to the
local candle makers in your area if
there is one probably make good candles
what do you guys think of like scented
soaps i'm like homemade sauce i've got i
know you're gonna say i mean i mean i
i'm only mentioning this because it's
because like sydney sydney recently
really got into meeting making
custom-made soaps and you know they
honestly honestly i'm i'm kind of sold
they i like the smell they look good
they look aesthetic
the only problem with like custom made
and scented soaps is that they look
great when you just get them when
they're like us when it starts to melt
when it's like a square block it looks
so aesthetic it looks great and then you
use it for like two weeks and like
shit's falling out of it yeah like she
puts like fresh flowers in it and it
looks [ __ ] amazing until the flowers
start [ __ ] falling off and
falling in the sink
i really like the like uh the haunted
syrup i don't know when i started
preferring it to
like uh like the pump soaps the hand
soap uh hand soap and body i like i like
the bricks oh i don't like the body
soaps you don't no no no i feel like it
really gets on your body i feel like it
really deep cleans you as opposed to
like the oh just like liquid soaps that
you get it depends what i love about
liquid soaps is that it feels like it
just coats your body
but like the hand soap really gets in
there and you can get some real nice
scents it just feels rough it feels
rough no that's what i like it feels
like it's really [ __ ] clean and i
feel like i'm dead i've never thought
that that deep i feel like
joey's just sitting here being like i'm
just like doesn't wash my body yes
you can get like soaps with like uh
i'm going off on one today yeah you can
get like soaps with stuff in them that
is like little uh coarse material so
that even when it's like you're we're
going away if it feels quite coarse i do
like if we're talking about specifically
i do like the kind of charcoal stuff
yeah so it's kind of like it's kind of
like scratchy against your skin yeah
yeah it feels like so it really gets in
your skin yeah so you don't feel like
you're losing grip as well yeah so you
can just kind of like go ham yeah
i like those because after you wash it
off you kind of feel like a cold man it
feels so good and it's like
that's that's what a clean skin feels
like yeah yeah
the reason i prefer liquid body soap at
least is because just because i feel
like the scents stick for longer like i
feel and smell funny actually like the
classic dove body soap that [ __ ] you
can't go wrong with that's great man
that just lathered that stuff on yeah
yeah yeah
in the uh onsens in japan there's like
no limit to how many pumps you can do
yeah yeah of like the shampoo and body
wash and i mean i take full advantage of
that normally it's like you you do one
cleaner in the [ __ ] onsen it's like
at least three yeah i'm like
it'll be like i'd be like how much
conditioner do i want i'm like don't
stop
more
i'll do like 10 pumps of conditioner i
won't stop i'm like i want every you
know conditioner sometimes doesn't feel
like it gets in your hair you know yeah
yeah i never use conditioner normally i
don't really feel like it's necessary
but in the in the onsen i'm like every
single like patch of hair that's left
gets gets conditioned and the body wash
i'm like
pump
pump another area pump you literally
turn into a [ __ ] yeti in the end
i'm just like i want to be fully soaked
up yeah
of course man i'm like i'm paying for it
it's just free part of it it's part of
the experience [ __ ] yeah
they just see me like [ __ ] slipping
over so i'm so soapy
[ __ ] i'm trying to get on this
i love it